en can academy desplegamos al chico
knows para decirte que hay algo mal con
tu página web pero solo te informamos
sobre problemas mayores podría haber
otras cosas mal con tu página web cosas
que no están muy bien de acuerdo con las
especificaciones de html pero los
navegadores te permiten continuar con
eso porque a los navegadores les gusta
ser indulgentes ellos sólo quieren que
tu página funcione así que termina sin
saber que hay algo mal con tu página web
por eso es buena idea correr tu página
en el servicio de validación w3 y en
realidad este revisara tu página y te
dirá si es válida o si hay alguna cosa
que no está muy bien en ella
para hacer eso vea validated punto w 3
punto org te dará opciones para
introducir una url cargar un archivo o
simplemente copiar y pegar y eso es lo
que haré
voy a tomar la página más reciente que
estaba mostrando en la guía paso a paso
y la pego aquí y la compruebo
tan tan se comprobó con éxito con html5
y no hay problemas con ella
fantástico vamos a probar con otra
este es nuestro ejemplo de vínculos
internos en html lo pegamos aquí y
comprobamos que hay un error y dos
advertencias vamos abajo dice que un
elemento image debe tener un atributo
alt o ese es algo típico olvidar el
atributo alt porque nosotros vemos las
imágenes pero no todos las ven así que
lo que tengo que hacer es regresar al
html y agregar el atributo alta la
imagen está aquí así que alt
igual fotografía de tim berners-lee
junto a su computadora
déjenme copiar y regresar pegar y volver
a comprobar
tan tan es una html válido cuando sea
posible deberías tratar de comprobar que
tus páginas web tengan un html válido
porque de esa manera puedes tener más
confianza de que el navegador las va a
interpretar exactamente como lo esperas
todo el tiempo ahora ve y trata de
validar algunas de tus páginas y ve como
resultan